for senior project richard is
researching how much money a college
graduate can expect to earn based on his
or her major he finds the following
interesting facts basketball superstar
Michael Jordan was a geology major at
the University of North Carolina there
were only three civil engineering majors
from the University of Montana they all
took the exact same job at the exact at
the same company earning the same salary
of the 35 finance majors from Wesleyan
University 32 got high-paying consulting
jobs and the other three were unemployed
for geology majors from the University
of North Carolina the median income will
likely be and we have some options here
less than equal to or greater than the
mean and then we have to answer the same
question for civil engineering majors
from Montana the median income Oh
actually the dues were both about median
the median income will be and we compare
it against the mean and then from flat
for finance majors from Wesleyan we're
going to compare the median income to
the mean so to visualize this a little
bit more I've copy and pasted this exact
same problem onto my scratch pad so here
it is I can now write on this so let's
think about each of these for geology
majors from UNC the median income will
be will likely be how will that compare
to the mean
well what did they tell us about UNC
they tell us that Michael Jordan was a
geology major at the University of North
Carolina so what is the what will the
distribution of salaries probably look
like so if we're thinking about the
University of North Carolina it probably
looks something like this and I'm going
to do a very very rough a very rough
distribution right over here and let's
say that this salary this would be a
salary of zero and let's say that this
is a salary of I don't know let me put a
salary of 50k here I'll do this in
thousands this let's say this is a
hundred thousand right over here and
then you have Michael Jordan who is
actually I'll do a little gap here
because he's so far up I don't know
exactly what he was making but it was
definitely in the tens of millions of
dollars a year so Michael Jordan is way
way way way up
here so if you were to make a histogram
or a plot of all of the salaries because
okay well you know maybe we have if you
put all of the all of the folks from
geology majors at University of North
Carolina well there's probably
especially right when they graduated
there's probably you know one two three
I could keep doing it a bunch of people
may be making 50k maybe some people
making a little bit more maybe some
people up here maybe some people there
some people there some people there like
there may be someone's making 100k maybe
someone so maybe it's a couple of people
up there maybe someone isn't making
anything maybe they did they weren't
able to find a job and then of course
you have Michael Jordan up here making
you know ten million dollars or twenty
million dollars or something like that
so when you have a situation like this
where you have this outlier of Michael
Jordan it's going to put it's going to
put that you one way I think about it
kind of tugs on the mean it wouldn't
affect the median because remember the
median is the middle value so it doesn't
matter how high this number is you could
make this a trillion dollars it's not
going to change what the middle value is
the middle value is still going to be
the same middle value you could move
this anywhere around in this range it's
not going to change the median but the
mean will change if this becomes really
really astronomically high it will
distort the actual mean here actually
would distort it a good bit so for the
geology majors from UNC the median
income is going to be lower than the
mean because Michael Jordan is pulling
the mean up so let me fill that in so
for geology majors from UNC the median
will be less than the mean now let's
think about the other ones for civil
engineering majors from Montana the
median income will be blank the mean
well they tell us there were only three
civil engineering majors from the
University of Montana they all took the
exact same job at the same company
earning the same salary so let's say all
three of them earned $50,000 let's say
that's their salary so you have if you
were to if you were to calculate the
mean it would be 50 plus 50 plus 50 over
3 which of course is 50 that would be
the mean if you wanted the median you
list the salaries in order and then you
take the middle one well the middle one
is 50
so in this case the median is equal to
the mean so let's fill that at that in
median is equal to the mean and then
finally let's go back to my scratch pad
whoops let me go back to my scratch pad
here for finance majors from Wesleyan
the median income will be blank the mean
so let's think about this distribution
here so here we have 35 out of the 35 32
got high-paying consulting jobs so let's
say that they were making you know they
were making six figures so so the
distribution might look something like
this where if this is zero and this is
let's say this is 50k and let's say that
this right over here is $100,000 a year
so 32 got high-paying consulting job so
you might have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24
25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 so the
distribution for the people who got the
jobs might look something like that
but there were three people who were
unemployed so let's say they got no
income so you have 1 2 3 so this is now
you have 3 outliers like the Michael
Jordan situation but instead of them
being very high they are very low so
they're going to pull the mean lower
they're not going to if these were 0 or
if these were 50 or if these were over
here they're not going to affect the
median the middle number is still going
to be the same but they are going to
pull down the mean so here I would say
that the median income will likely be
higher will likely be greater than the
mean because because the mean is going
to get pulled down by these outliers
these three people not making anything
so let's fill that out for finance
majors from Wesleyan the median income
will likely be greater than the mean and
let's check our answer and we got it
right